travis gales was serving as the top
health official of montgomery county
maryland when the kovid 19 pandemic
arrived his mission was simple in regard
to the county's one million residents
keep them well and keep them from dying
as hospitals across the u.s filled with
patients suffering from kovid 19 gales
recommended businesses and schools
clothes and for everyone to wear masks
the policies were restrictive but worked
to keep cases low and the community in
this liberal suburb of washington d.c
was supportive gail says
but then came signs of impatience well
things became more political
the discussion moved from
hi good morning here's where our cases
are here's what the test positivity rate
is and those kinds of things too
well
things are different why can't we do
this activity and why is this particular
thing closed and why is this
jurisdiction open and why aren't we open
gail says he also received threats an
email shared with al jazeera gales was
called a power hungry loser and an enemy
of the people and will be dealt with
accordingly when i would leave the
office i would try to park in different
places and i would take different routes
home because you know quite frankly i
was concerned about someone following me
public health officials all over the
country have reported similar
experiences or worse
exhausted from long hours of work then
targeted by members of their own
communities for recommending unpopular
but life-saving mandates a year and a
half into the pandemic hundreds have
called it quits we just can't have
people on public service being
threatened for doing their jobs
maryland state senator rong young has
proposed making threatening a public
health worker a crime
but the trend in most of the country has
been the opposite with lawmakers in 32
states introducing 100 new laws to
restrict public health actions citing
freedom of choice and making it harder
to enforce mask and vaccine mandates
it's happening to a great extent because
a politics
i mean if we can't trust and believe the
people that are experts in the field
were in bad shape
it's feared the backlash against
pandemic restrictions has left the u.s
less prepared for the next pandemic
gales for one is among the public health
officers who have resigned
healy is behind a county that with his
early push now has among the highest
vaccination rates in the country but
that still hasn't named his replacement
heidi jo castro al jazeera silver spring
maryland